sometimes small unassuming moments in a
movie don't reveal their significance
until later here's a look at the most
rewarding not so minor moments and great
pictures those seemingly random faraway
details that happen to be a lot more
important than you realized
spoilers ahead JJ Abrams 2009 Star Trek
reboot wowed audiences with a killer
explanation for presenting the original
Enterprise crew played by younger actors
it takes place in an alternate timeline
one clue to the film's timeline shifting
conceits comes in the opening scene
characters can briefly be seen using
communicators which look almost
identical to the ones from the original
Star Trek series when Nero jumped
timelines in order to stage his assault
his incursion at consequences after his
attack the timeline was subtly altered
which manifests in the communicates is
looking completely different from the
originals every time we see them after
that point in the movie John Carpenter's
The Thing is an absolute masterclass in
suspense and much of the film's tension
is mined from the shape-shifting nature
of its alien menace and the isolated
setting of an Antarctic Research Center
trapped together in close quarters those
stationed at the base are forced into a
deadly game of hide-and-seek with a
predator capable of impersonating any
living organism although it's a
situation that could easily have been
avoided if any member of their team
spoke Norwegian the film opens with a
helicopter tracking and attempting to
kill a dog as it flies over the tundra
it makes its way to the American base
where the puzzled Americans understand
that nothing of the situation other than
that the Norwegians are obviously in a
blind panic and fortunately he's shot
dead before he can tried to explain
what's going on and the Americans have
no idea where he was actually saying
anyone who speaks Norwegian would have
known he was giving them a warning
saying get the hell away from that thing
that's not a dog it's some sort of thing
it's imitating a dog it isn't real get
away you idiots given the film's bleak
and ambiguous ending it just might have
been the misunderstanding that doom the
planet and get out Chris a black man is
invited to the home of his white
girlfriend's parents only to discover
that the family is involved in a
nefarious plot to hijack the bodies of
healthy young black people to host the
minds of rich elderly whites it's a
shocking twist unless you speak Swahili
the film's main title theme is a piece
called sea Keeley's a koala hangar and
its lyrics contain an important message
for Chris and the audience translated
they say brother listen to the ancestors
run you need to run far listen to the
truth brother listen to the ancestors
run run to save yourself listen to the
ancestors Pele confirmed in a GQ
interview shortly before the film's
release but this was fully intentional
saying the words are issuing a warning
to Chris the whole idea of the movie is
get out it's what we're screaming at the
character on screen
you know
Robert Eggers the which rewards viewers
for paying close attention and it's also
prone to taking sudden and hard left
turns into the bizarre and surreal
events before the film's hapless family
of religious outcasts has seemed like
they can only be explained by the
supernatural but in the film's first act
it gives away the possibility that there
may be a different explanation in an
early scene father William and son Jonas
attending to the family's meager crop of
corn which appears to have been affected
by some type of fungus indeed it's been
noted by some fans that it looks like a
very specific type a gut which has known
to cause a variety of symptoms when
ingested including mania psychosis and
hallucinations it's even been suggested
that agar may have played a role in the
events leading up to the Salem witch
trials and Eggers himself all but
confirmed the theory in a slate
end-of-year there are clues about
different interpretations so for example
the rot on the corn is agate which is a
hallucinogenic fungus so if you wanted
to take that route you could in the
first act of blue ruin we meet Dwight a
homeless drifter living out of his
battered blue Plymouth sedan who
exhibits signs of profound PTSD it's
later revealed that Dwight's parents
were brutally shot to death in their car
by a local bully named Wade years
earlier and waves and pending release
from prison has Dwight's already fragile
mental state at the breaking point
sharp-eyed viewers may have been able to
deduce that Dwight's life had been
marred by violent crime within the
film's first few minutes his blue
plymouth looks pretty much like any
other cheap and neglected betta car you
might say except for one crucial detail
the bullet holes adorning the driver's
side it's not just a cheap beater it's
his parents old vehicle the very one
they were gunned down in Dwight has
literally been living in the memory of
their murder which makes his quest for
brutal revenge all the more
understandable Marvel's crossover
blockbuster The Avengers features a
number of moments which subtly
foreshadow later events in one of its
funniest scenes Tony Stark calls out a
SHIELD agent on the deck of the
Helicarrier for not doing his job that
man is playing Galaga
we wouldn't notice but we did as it
turns out the joke has a deeper
resonance and just showing how poorly
staffed she'll des Gallagher is an
unwinnable game in which the player must
defend against increasingly aggressive
swarms of alien invaders not unlike the
tusks the Avengers face in the film's
climax the marvel cinematic universes
version of spider-man finally made its
debut in 2016 s Captain America Civil
War when the Avengers are split down the
middle over the government initiative to
regulate them Peter Parker is recruited
by Tony Stark as a fail-safe in the
looming fight against Captain America
it's the beginning of what will become a
warm almost father some relationship
between stark and Parker and with one
nuanced line delivery Tom Holland cues
the audience into the fact that Peter
looks up to Iron Man in a most profound
away your spider boy spider-man not now
onesie or not it's not a onesie
the reason Peter's embarrassed doesn't
come down to his age in the MCU Stark is
the only hero to use the man suffix
implying that Parker has modeled himself
after his idol ironically it seems like
he's got a lot more in common with a
different superhero you got an art kid
were you from Gliese Brooklyn in and
amuse Scotty's 2017 theatrical
adaptation of its actor bill skarsgård
fought whole new dimensions of
brain-melting terror to the parts of
penny wise from his very first
appearance on screen he gives off the
distinct vibe of a vicious feral animal
Millie disguised as a clown but also
gives the audience a clue as to how it
subtly manipulates its prey Georgie the
younger brother of main protagonist bill
loses his paper boat in a storm drain
but there's something down there ready
to lure him in with the promise of
returning it to him when its eyes first
appear in the darkness they're
distinctly greenish-yellow but when
Pennywise steps out of the shadows to
reveal itself the shade of its eyes has
changed to blow the same color as his
brother Bill's eyes suck like a nice boy
I think a lot of friends
three of my brothers my best guess where
is he
it just may have been the comforting hue
of his brothers eyes I convinced Georgie
to make the fatal mistake of trusting
Pennywise for the capper on Hugh
Jackman's 17-year run as Wolverine Logan
showed audiences a grim future for
mutant kind none have been born for a
quarter century seizures have driven
Charles Xavier telepathy haywire and
it's heavily employed that his episodes
have killed off most of the mutants that
were left Xavier is being cared for by
Logan in Caliban or hiding out in an
abandoned rusted out mill and the
studios may have noticed that its
interior is a pretty dead-on visual
reference to his earlier days that many
points of sunlight shining through the
holes into the darkness interior of the
male a highly reminiscent of cerebro the
machine Xavier once used to track
mutants these lights represent every
living person on the planet cerebro
would render the locations of all
mutants worldwide which appeared as
points of light in three-dimensional
space The Hideout ceiling isn't just a
cool throwback to the glory days of the
x-men oh no that would be too easy
there's something else going on here
where the lights ones represented living
beings they are now just holes because
all of the mutants are gone pivoting
from dark family tragedy to supernatural
thriller hereditary keeps you completely
unsure as to whether any of it is
actually happening you can't really be
sure if the supernatural goings-on are
really taking place or if Annie's mental
illness is manifesting in seemingly
supernatural ways that is unless we were
paying attention during a scene in the
support group when Annie talks about how
our brother complained about their
mother trying to put people inside of
him it could be interpreted as
schizophrenia except that we later find
out that this is exactly what Annie's
mom was trying to do she was part of a
coven searching for a male host for the
demon Peyman and her attempts to put
Peyman inside her son was rationalized
away as symptoms of schizophrenia 2016's
arrival gave us a heady sci-fi scenario
12 alien spacecraft descend upon
different points of the earth the US
military recruits an expert linguist to
decipher their communications which
appear a circular complex glyphs other
nations are also in on the efforts which
takes a harrowing term on the alien
beings which have been dubbed
hepta pods appear to make a reference to
using a weapon none of the involved
countries are able to agree on the
interpretation but a rivals use of
communication issues are hinted early on
in the nicknames that the American team
gives to to aliens they're called Abbott
and Costello which is obviously a
reference to the famous comedy duo whose
most iconic sketch who's on first was
essentially one long series of humorous
miscommunications what we've got here is
failure
mouki the nicknames given to the
creatures serves as a clue to sharp
audiences about what's really going on
[Music]